हेलो
एवरीवन एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
प्लीज बताइए आई एम
ऑडिबल आईम ऑडिबल लाउड एंड
क्लियर ओके जस्ट फॉर ू मिनट बाकी सबको आने
दीजिए अभी तक ओनली 40 स्टूडेंट्स ही आए
हैं तो एटलीस्ट 100 प्स तो आइए
और लास्ट क्लास से रिलेटेड मुझे किसी का
कोई भी डाउट्स नहीं लगा किसी ने डाउट्स
नहीं पूछा तो मेरी तरफ से अभी तक लास्ट
क्लास के रिगार्डिंग कोई भी डाउट्स नहीं
है क्योंकि जब मैं कमेंट सेक्शन पढ़ रहा
था आपका तो किसी ने भी वहां पर कोई भी
डाउट नहीं पूछा जिसने डाउट पूछा था उन का
सेम टाइम मैंने रिप्लाई कर दिया
था क्योंकि मैंने आपको बताया है कि आपको
जो भी डाउट लगता है क्लास से रिलेटेड व
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है क्लास एंड होने
के बाद कमेंट सेक्शन में आप डाउट पूछ सकते
हो जिसको क्या करूंगा मैं एनालाइज करूंगा
देखूंगा उसके बाद नोट डाउन कर लूंगा और
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम उसको डिस्कस करेंगे
तो आज का जो चलो मैं आपको बता देता हूं आज
का जो सेशन होने वाला है टोटली प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन है जिसमें मैं कुछ टूल्स के बारे में
बताऊंगा आपको जिसकी हेल्प से आप कैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो वो काफी
पॉपुलर टूल्स है उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम स्विच करेंगे एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग मुझे पता है कि काफी
टाइम वैसे तो टूल्स बहुत सारे होते हैं हर
एक टूल को कवर करेंगे तो आप सबके लिए
बोरिंग हो जाएगा और आप लोग क्लास में आना
छोड़ दो क्योंकि जिस परपज से आप आए हो वो
परपज इस कोर्स का पार्ट नहीं है क्योंकि
जो मैं अभी करवा रहा हूं जितने बेसिक से
करवा रहा हूं इस कोर्स को डिफाइन नहीं
करता कि एक एडवांस कोर्स है क्योंकि एक
बेसिक कोर्स वाला ही पार्ट करवा रहा हूं
क्योंकि बेसिक कोर्स वाला पार्ट इसलिए
करवा रहा हूं सो दैट कि जो अ न्यू
स्टूडेंट्स हैं उनको हेल्प मिले समझने में
तो अभी नेक्स्ट जो क्लास होगी तो नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम स्विच करेंगे एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग बिल्कुल जीरो से हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे और एक मतलब कि जहां तक हमें जरूरत
है उस लेवल तक लेके जाएंगे एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में हम ज्यादातर फोकस
करेंगे एन मैप टूल के बारे में जो एन मैप
टूल्स है आपको पता है नेटवर्क मैपर मैपर्स
है आपने पहले यूज भी किया होगा जिसने नहीं
यूज किया है सुना होगा तो जिसने अगर ए मैप
के बारे में थोड़ा थोड़ा बहुत सुना है
थोड़ी भी थोड़ा बहुत भी उसको नहीं पता अगर
ए मैप के बारे में नहीं आता उसको उसको
चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं है मैं बिल्कुल
जीरो टू एक लेवल तक ए मैप को करवाऊंगी
उसके बाद आप ब्लाइंड अकॉर्डिंग टू चैलेंज
आप एन मैप को कहीं पर भी यूज कर पाओगे इस
लेवल तक मैं टोटली एक कांसेप्चुअल
कांसेप्ट में पूरा एन मैप एक डिटेल्स
ट्यूटोरियल्स टाइप मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा क्योंकि वो हमारे कोर्स की ज्यादा
जरूरत है इवन हमारे को की नहीं हर एक
एग्जाम की हर एक इंडस्ट्री की वो
रिक्वायरमेंट क्योंकि एन मैप का यूज होता
ही होता है तो एन मैप पे ज्यादा फोकस
करेंगे और देन उसके बाद जब एक बार एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हो जाएगा एन्यूमरेशन
करेंगे उसके बाद हम यही सारे स्टेप्स जो
तीन स्टेप्स है वो हम मेटा स्प्लटर मेटा
स्प्लटर स्प्ड की हेल्प से भी वो सारी चीज
हम परफॉर्म करेंगे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
प्लस एन्यूमरेशन पार्ट देन फिर जैसे हम
कोर्स स्टार्ट करें कोर्स तो स्टार्ट हो
चुका है जैसे हम कोर्स के अंदर आगे
बढ़ेंगे तो जैसे एक्सप्लोइट होंगे तो
दोनों टाइप से हम कवर करने की कोशिश
करेंगे विद द हेल्प ऑफ मेटा स्लोट प्लस
में विद द हेल्प ऑफ मैनुअल टेक्निक्स
दोनों तरीकों से हम कोस के चैलेंज को
सॉल्व करेंगे तो यह मेरा फर्द प्लान है
आपको मैंने पहले बता दिया है तो प्लीज
डोंट मिस एनी क्लास और जैसे जैसे हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे वैसे वैसे हम क्या करेंगे कि
ज्यादा टूल्स के बारे में ज्यादा डिटेल्स
और ज्यादा एक फोकस वे में एक मतलब एक गुड
वे में और मतलब प्रॉपर एक रोड मैप पर काम
करेंगे हम ओके
तो स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं मैं अभी
78 स्टूडेंट्स आ गए हैं तो मुझे लग
स्टार्ट करना चाहिए हमें तो टोटली
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन आज का और कुछ थोड़ा बहुत
बचेगा पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का पार्ट
उसको हम बीच में कभी भी कवर कर लेंगे
क्योंकि मैं आपको बोर नहीं करूंगा क्योंकि
मुझे भी ज्यादा पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
पढ़ाने में सच बता इंटरेस्ट नहीं बनता
क्योंकि लेकिन आप लोगों के लिए डिलीवर कर
रहा हूं क्योंकि पैस इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
आप खुद से करोगे तो उतना ज्यादा ही
एक्सप्लोर कर
पाओगे ओके तो अभी हम जूम कर देते जो भी
हमारे लिए जरूरतें हैं टर्मिनल
सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है एवरीवन
विजिबल किसी को ऐसा तो नहीं लग रहा कि सर
स्क्रीन छोटी है यह थोड़ा सा और जूम कीजिए
या जूम आउट कर लीजिए किसी को ऐसा तो नहीं
लग रहा
ओके तो सबसे पहले हम पढ़ने वाले हैं वह है
सर्टिफिकेट ट्रांसपेरेंसी के थ्रू हम
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे अभी ये
सर्टिफिकेट ट्रांसपेरेंसी क्या होती है
देखि एक वेबसाइट है आप सबको पता होगा सबने
किया भी होगा यह है सीआरटी ड एसए एक
वेबसाइट है सीआरटी ड एसए यहां पर अभी इस
तरीके से आपको देखने को मिलती है वेबसाइट
मैं आपको जूम करके दिखा देता हूं यह रहा
यह वेबसाइट सर्टिफिकेट सर्च बेसिकली आपको
पता होगा जब भी हम एक वेबसाइट होस्ट करते
हैं जब भी हम एक वेबसाइट बनाते हैं उसके
बाद उसको होस्ट करते हैं तो हम उसको
सिक्योर करने के लिए क्या करते हैं एसएसएल
या टीएल सर्टिफाई करवाते हैं एचटीटीपीएस
लेने के लिए अब जब एसएसएल और टी एलएस की
जब सिक्योरिटी हम लेते हैं तो उसके लिए हम
क्या करते हैं अपने डोमेन को उसके लिए हम
क्या करते हैं डिजिटल सर्टिफिकेट लेते हैं
डिजिटल सर्टिफिकेट क्या करता है बेसिकली
आपको डिजिटल बेसिकली आपको यह वेरीफाई
करवाता है कि जो सर्विस जिस वेबसाइट से आप
सर्विसेस ले रहे हो या जिस भी वेबसाइट को
आप यूज कर रहे हो वह एक वैलिड वेबसाइट है
ओके जो पब्लिक की और प्राइवेट की के फॉर्म
में काम करते हैं और जो सर्टिफिकेट इशू
किया जाता है वह किसके द्वारा इशू किया
जाता है आपके रूट सीए के द्वारा और बहुत
सारे रूट सी अवेलेबल है तो यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन पब्लिकली अवेलेबल रहती है और
यह जो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन है इसका एक एक डे
बेस क्रिएट किया गया है अब जो सर्टिफिकेट
ड एसस जैसी वेबसाइट है यह उस डेटा को
डेटाबेस को क्या कर सकती है एक्सेस कर
सकती है जिससे हम क्या कर सकते हैं कि
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं कि जो
पर्टिकुलर जो डोमेन है जो पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट है वो उसका जो सर्टिफिकेट है
एक्सपायर्ड है वैलिड है इनवैलिड है वो इस
परपज से लेकिन एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हम
क्या करते हैं कि इससे अपना सब डोमेन
एन्यूमरेशन करते हैं इसे हम क्या करते हैं
सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन फॉर एग्जांपल कैसे की
दो तरीके हैं एक तो हम मैनुअल वे है यहां
पर एक तो मैनुअल वे है दूसरा क्या है हम
ऑटोमेशन मैं दोनों तरीके बताऊंगा मैनुअल
में फॉर एग्जांपल मैं फाइंड आउट कर रहा
हूं एक
टेस्ट च वेबसाइट वी ट्राई डेनिक्स को
ट्राई करते हैं
डेनिक्स कॉ ओके जैसे ही मैं सर्च करता हूं
हमारी वेबसाइट को इससे रिलेटेड जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है इसके डेटाबेस में
आपके पास स्क्रीन आपके स्क्रीन के ऊपर शो
जाएगी ना
विजिबल थोड़ा सा स्लो काम कर रहा है
क्योंकि हम वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट में काम कर
रहे
हैं ओके ये देखिए फनि से रिलेटेड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का जो नाम है या जो भी डोमेन
है उससे रिलेटेड जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन है इस
वेबसाइट के पास अवेलेबल होगी जैसे देखिए ब
academic.com अमी एक de.com देन de.com
पोल de.com
एम de.com एक de.com एंड देखिए दे लट ऑफ
इफ अभी मुझे इससे कोई मतलब नहीं देखो कि
यह सर्टिफिकेट आईडी है कब इसको लॉक किया
गया था नॉट बिफोर नॉट आफ्टर इसकी सारी
वैलिडिटी लिखी हुई है कि इसवर का नाम क्या
है यह सारी चीज इसमें लिखी है बट मेरे को
मतलब क्या है मेरे को बेसिकली यहां पर
मतलब है हमारे डोमेन और सब डोमेन से
क्योंकि मेरा बाकी इन चीजों से मुझे कभी
कोई मतलब नहीं है तो मुझे य से सॉरी मुझे
जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए वो चाहिए मुझे सब
डोमेन और डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन यह देखिए
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है तो यहां
से भी एक तरीका है कि आप फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हैं मुझे यह बताइए कि मैं इस
इंफॉर्मेशन को कैसे यूज कर सकता हूं देखिए
मैं यहां पर इसको सिंपली मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा इस पूरी की पूरी इंफॉर्मेशन को
कॉपी करना होगा कंट्रोल ऑल बेसिकली मुझे
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करना पड़ेगा कॉपी
करना होगा ऐसे क्योंकि कॉपी करके उसके बाद
मुझे क्या करना होगा मैनुअल तरीके से उसको
पेस्ट करना होगा पेस्ट करके अपने वर्ड
फाइल के अंदर या आप अपने बोल सकते हैं
एक्सेल के अंदर देन उसके बाद हर एक एक-एक
करके आपको फिल्टर करना पड़े ये तरीका
दूसरा इसको दूसरा क्या है दूस ऑटोमेशन
तरीका मैं आपको बताऊंगा दूसरा एक और तरीका
और किसी वेबसाइट को क्या करते
हैं कौन सी एक वेबसाइट टेस्ट वल्नरेबल
वेबसाइट होती थी ना एक एक वेबसाइट का नाम
था वलन टेस्ट ड
पीएचपी यह थी
क्या टेस्ट पीएवन web.com ओके देखिए टेस्ट
पप ww.com अगर इससे रिलेटेड मुझे
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए देखिए कि टेस्ट पीएचपी
डॉट वनवेब कॉम ओके य रहा वनवेब
कॉ वेबड कॉ यह इंफॉर्मेशन य पर सर्च कर
सकता
हूं नन फाउंड य पर कुछ भी फाउंड नहीं मिला
क्योंकि इससे रिलेटेड कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है अगर फॉर एग्जांपल मैं सर्च करता
हूं इसके अंदर फॉर
एग्जांपल हम
च वेबसाइट वी कैन सर्च इट आउट ऑन
इट हैकर वन कॉ यह
देखिए देखिए अभी ये हैकर वन से रिलेटेड जो
भी इंफॉर्मेशन है सारे डोमेन सब डोमेन की
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी डड हैर
1.com
एटी एटीए मैनेज हैर सब डोमेन का सब डोमेन
सब डोमेन का सब डोमेन वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
जो भी पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है इन्होंने
क्योंकि सब डोमेन को रजिस्टर करवाया होगा
उसके अगेंस्ट सर्टिफिकेट लिया होगा तो
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां इनके रिकॉर्ड्स में
अवेलेबल है देखिए यहां पर एक तो तरीका यह
है कि आप इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर सकते हो थ्रो
जीआई ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है यहां से कट कॉपी पेस्ट एंड
हर एक चीज को रिमूव करना है देन उसके बाद
बाद शर्ट करना है फिल्टर करना है एक ये
तरीका है दूसरा मैं क्या कर सकता हूं इसी
को जैसे कि मैं इसी को कर सकता हूं ऑटोमेट
मतलब एक स्क्रिप्ट है स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं सारे के सारे सब
डोमस को मैं क्या कर सकता हूं अपनी एक
फाइल के अंदर सेव कर सकता हूं कैसे देखिए
अभी इसको न्यू पेज को ओपन करते हैं और एक
गिट हप रिपोजिटरी है जिसका नाम
है वन ए
ी सर्ट डट एस सी आरटी ड
एसए ओके देखिए यह है इसका य गिट हब पेज है
देन य
नाउ सिंपली य क्या है एक आपका जो पेज आपको
दिखाई दे रहा है यह
आपका एक बे स्क्रिप्ट है मुझे इसको क्या
करना है सिंपली रो फॉर्मेट में करना है
क्या क्या रो क्लिक ऑन द रो एंड देन इसको
जूम कर देता हूं एक ब आपके स्क्रीन के
सामने दिखाई दे रहा होगा और इसको मैं क्या
करूंगा सिंपली कॉपी करूंगा कंट्रोल ए एंड
इसको राइट
क्लिक कॉपी कॉपी किया उसके बाद मैं अपने
टर्मिनल को ओपन करूंगा जैसे मैं टर्मिनल
को ओपन करूंगा तो यहां पर मैं क्या करता
हूं एक फाइल ओपन करूंगा
नो उसके बाद
सर्ट बैस डॉट एस एच के नाम से मैं एक
फाइल क्रिएट करूंगा देखो अभी यहां पर
सिंपली क्या राइट क्लिक एंड पेस्ट क्लिप
बोर्ड सारा सारा कोड मैंने यहां पर क्या
कर दिया पेस्ट कर दिया कौन सा बेस कोड को
स्क्रिप्टिंग को स्क्रिप्ट कोड हैय
बेसिकली बेस में कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स
मुझे मैंने इसको सेव कर दिया अब मैं एलस
करता हूं सिंपली तो एलस करते हम आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने दिखाई देगा कौन सा सर्ट
बस्टड एस अब मैं इसको क्या कर देता हूं
परमिशन प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं कौन सी
एग्जीक्यूटिंग परमिशन इसको क्या करता हूं
मैं एग्जीक्यूटिंग परमिशन प्रोवाइड करता
हूं तो सीच मोड कैसे परमिशन दे सकते हैं
प्लस x उसके बाद सीआरटी बस डट एसए हिट
एंटर देन वी सक्सेसफुली पास द परमिशन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन टू सर्ट बस्टड एस
फाइल ओके यहां पर मैंने एग्जीक्यूटेबल
परमिशन दे दी कैसे आपको कैसे पता चलेगा एल
एस हान एल करोगे तो आप देख सकते हो हाइन
एल देखिए जो फाइल है सट सर्ट बस्टड एस इस
फाइल के ऊपर क्या परमिशन रीड राइट
एग्जीक्यूटेबल रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूटेबल और
रीड और एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन है अब मुझे
सिंपली अगर मैं इसको रन करूंगा तो सिंपली
रन करने के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं
एग्जीक्यूटेबल
सर्ट बस्टड एसए और सिंपली हिट रन कर दे
देखिए अभी इस तरीके से आपको देखने को मिल
रही है इसका यूसेज क्या है आपको यूज करना
है सर्ड एस टारगेट का नाम अब मुझे जिस भी
डोमेन या सब डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए वो
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
इसके अंदर सेव कर सकता हूं तो जैसे कि अभी
मैं हैकर वन की ट्राई करता हूं तो सिंपली
हम क्या करेंगे कि यह रहा सर्ट बस्टड एच
यहां पर टारगेट नेम टारगेट का नाम मैं
रखता
हूं हैर वड कॉ हैर 1.com देखिए अभी सिंपली
अगर मैं हिट एंटर करता हूं तो आपको सारा
का सारा आउटपुट आपकी स्क्रीन के ऊपर दिखाई
देगा लेकिन मुझे क्या करना है एक फाइल के
अंदर स्टोर करना अगर मुझे एक फाइल के अंदर
स्टोर करना है तो मैं उसको क्या करूंगा एक
तो तरीका मेरे पास है रिडक करके देन
आउटपुट रिडक करूंगा एक फाइल के फाइल का
नेम क्या रखूंगा
मैं हैकर
वन उसके
बाद सब डोमेन डॉट टी एक्सटी हिट एंटर
देखिए इट विल टेक टाइम और जितने भी सब
डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन है वो सारी की सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन य क्या करेगी इस फाइल के अंदर
स्टोर कर देगा टूल्स सक्सेसफुली स्टोर कर
दिया अब मैं एलस करता हूं तो आपके सामने
दिखाई दे रहा होगा हैकर वन सब डटी एक्सटी
ओके अभी मैं क्या करता हूं इने खुद से भी
स्टोर कर दिया और य मैं क्या करता हूं अभी
कैट करते हैं हम हैकर
वन सब डोमेन डटी एक्सटी अगर मैं इसके अंदर
चेक करता हूं कितनी वैल्यू
है तो डब्लू स कमांड होती है वर्ड काउंट
हाइन एल देखिए दे वन सब डोमन आर अवेलेबल
रिलेटेड टू द हैकर वन और इसने सारे के
सारे क्या कर दिए इस फाइल के अंदर स्टोर
कर दिए अभी मैं कैट करके इंफॉर्मेशन देखना
चाहूं तो वो भी मैं देख सकता हूं हैकर
वन टी एक्सटी टेंटर यह सारे के सारे जो सब
डोमेन है उनकी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइल के
अंदर स्टोर करके रख दी दूसरा तरीका क्या
था कि एक और तरीके से मैं क्या करता हूं
आउटपुट को देख भी सकता हूं टर्मिनल के ऊपर
दूसरा एक फाइल के अंदर सेव भी कर सकता हूं
कैसे देखिए
सर्ट बेस डॉट एस एच देन उसके बाद मेरा
नेक्स्ट टारगेट मैं रखता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल हमारी वेबसाइट छोटी है और हैकर
वन
चलो हम रखते हैं अभी उरी करते हैं
चलो कोई भी मिलि ससली इसको यूज नहीं करे
मैं आपको प्रैक्टिस के लिए दिखा रहा हूं ड
कोई भी इस चीज को विदाउट परमिशन प्रैक्टिस
नहीं करेगा तो
ड
कॉम देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता पाइप
सिंबल यूज करता हूं एक कमांड होती है टी
आपका आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर शो करेगी और फाइल
के अंदर स्टोर भी करेगी तो मैं चेक करता
हूं
र
सब
डोमेन डॉट टी एक्सटी और ट एंटर देखिए
यह सारा आउटपुट स्क्रीन पर भी शो करेगी और
इस फाइल के अंदर भी स्टोर कर देगी इस
इंफॉर्मेशन
को ना बर्स के जितने भी डोमेन सब डोमन की
इंफॉर्मेशन व सारी सारी उसने क्या की एक
फाइल के अंदर स्टोर करके रख दी देखिए चलो
अभी मैं क्या करता इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन देखते
एलस य रहा उ सबड एक्सटी कैट करते हैं तो
कितने उ सबड एक्सटी
टी एक्सटी अगर मैं इसको काउंट करता
[संगीत]
हूं डब्लू सी हाइन एल देखिए
183 डोमन सब डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन इसके
अंदर है तो इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हो
जो सर्टिफिकेट ट्र ट्रांसपेरेंसी है जो
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल जो डिजिटल सर्टिफिकेट की
इंफॉर्मेशन है एसएसएल टीएल से रिलेटेड
उसके थ्रू जो भी डोमेन सब डोमेन
एन्यूमरेशन इंफॉर्मेशन जितने भी सब डोमेन
रिलेटेड टू किसी भी वेबसाइट के वह सारे
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आप एक मैनुअल तरीके से और
दूसरा ऑटोमेशन तरीके से गैदर कर सकते हो
एवरीवन गट
क्लियर पहले टूल के बारे में आप किस तरीके
से इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो रिलेटेड
टू योर सब डोमेन या डोमेन एवरीवन गट
क्लियर
बताइए पता चल गया कैसे टूल को यूज करना
है कट कॉपी पेस्ट एंड उसका यूसेज पार्ट
क्या
है लायन गेमिंग से नो व्हाई
नो वेसट आप खुद से चूज
कीजिए मैं आपको बता देता हूं कहां पर
अवेलेबल है यह यह रहा गो बैक दिस व जो गिट
अप लिंक है यह रहा आपके स्क्रीन के सामने
अगर मैं कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और एक बार
में गो बैक करते
हैं यहां पर पेस्ट कर देता हूं चलो
कंट्रोल
व और यहां पर अगर आपको जूम नहीं हो रहा तो
मैं यहां पर करता हूं अगर पेस्ट तो होगा
नहीं यह उधर ही पेस्ट हो रहा है तो प्लीज
इसको एक काम कर लीजिए यह जूम नहीं होगा तो
इसको देख लीजिए एक बार
और इस पेज को अगर मैं ओपन करूं तो यह वाला
गिट पेज
है यह रहा मैं इसको जूम कर देता हूं अगर
आपको स्क्रीनशॉट चाहिए तो स्क्रीनशॉट ले
सकते
हो पास कर दूं
चलो एंड पास करने के लिए मुझे आउट करना
पड़ेगा च चैट में पेस्ट कर स सकते इधर नो
ओके सबको मिल
गया ओके चलो नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं गो
बैक टू आवर स्क्रीन नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट हम यूज कर सकते हैं सिंसस आपने
सुना होगा अगर नहीं पता होगा तो मैं आपको
बता देता हूं जैसे आपने सडन को यूज किया
था ऐसे ही
आप सी ई एन एस वाई एस सेंसस को यूज कर
सकते
हैं इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के लिए यह भी एक
पे टूल लेकिन इसको ज आप लॉग इन करोगे फ्री
लॉग इन करोगे तो
आपको 200 प्लस क्यूरीज और स्कैनिंग फ्री
मिलती है तो आप इस पर प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हो जैसे कि मैं इसमें लॉगिन करता हूं
मैंने रजिस्टर किया था तो इस अगर डेमो के
रूप में लोगे या वो करोगे तो क्या कर सकते
हो आपको कुछ 250 तक रिक्वेस्ट आपको मिल
सकती है जो आप इसको यूज करके देख सकते हो
जैसे मैं इसको जूम कर देता हूं अभी के लिए
मेरे पास इसका अकाउंट है मैं आपके सामने
इसको यूज करके दिखाता हूं
स
और अगर हम देखें आज ओनली 66 है 100 भी
नहीं
इवन 90 भी नहीं है तो डोंट वरी नेक्स्ट
क्लास आपकी उतनी डिले
होगी आप मुझे डी मोटिवेट कीजिए और मैं
आपको डी मोटिवेट
करूंगा नो
प्रॉब्लम अगर मुझे अपना बेस्ट कंटेंट और
बेस्ट कोर्स देना है ना तो मुझे तो
स्टूडेंट तो चाहिए अब मुझे स्टूडेंट नहीं
मिलेंगे तो क्लास डिले करूंगा नो इशू चलो
अभी यहां पर मैं क्या कर सकता हूं होस्ट
सर्च कर सकता हूं सर्टिफिकेट सर्च कर सकता
हूं जैसे मैं होस्ट रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं तो होस्ट मेरा
भी क्या है अभी हम होस्ट रखते हैं फिर से
ब को रख लेते
हैं
देखिए यहां पर यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल
है स द आईपी एड्रेस यूनाइटेड स्टेट ओपन
वीपीएन एंड एसटीपी
8443 दे लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन अ रिलेटेड टू द
र देखिए जकरी वर्डप्रेस क लेबल्स होस्ट
फिल्टर य हमारा देखिए एटीटीपी सर्विस लॉट
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक जैसे आप जो इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिलती थी ना उसके ऊपर जैसे
मैं इसी को ओपन करता हूं होस्ट के ऊपर यह
क्या
है
u fight.com यह
एक डोमेन देखिए यह एक सब डोमेन है उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन है राउटिंग इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल
है सर्विसेस इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है एंड
ओपन वीपीएन का पोर्ट नंबर मेंशन है एंड
देखिए इसके अपाचे एप्ट वट ओके एटीटीपी
8443 टीसीपी पोर्ट को यूज किया जा रहा है
यह डिटेल्स अवेलेबल है फर फ नॉट फाउंड ओके
देन टील हैंक 1.3 यूज किया जा रहा है
साइफर कौन सी यूज की जा रही है दे लॉट ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन ल अवेलेबल कंट्री यूनाइटेड
स्टेट टैक्सस प्लेनो इस तरीके से आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल सकती है जैसे यह
थ हु इंफॉर्मेशन देख सकते हो उसके बारे
में यह रहा ये इसकी हुज इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रही है देख लो तो इस तरीके
से आप क्या कर सकते हो इस पर भी
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो रिलेटेड
टू अगर सर्टिफिकेट इंफॉर्मेशन देखोगे आप
तो ब की सर्टिफिकेट इंफॉर्मेशन भी आपको
यहां पर देखने को मिल जाएगी
एक एक करके मैं आपको सब कुछ बता रहा हूं
अखिलेश राव और यह भी आप यूज कर सकते हो एट
टाइम आप इसको जब रजिस्टर लॉगइन करोगे तो
यह मेरी अगर मैं आपको बताऊ तो मेरी फेक
मेल है आप कुछ भी ट्राई कर लो यह फेक मेल
है और जब यह फेक मेल है तो सोच लीजिए फेक
मेल से मेरे को 250 रिक्वेस्ट मिली हुई है
मैं इसको सर्च कर सकता हूं तो यू कैन समझ
सकते हो कि आपके पास फेक मेल्स के थ्रू आप
फ्री अकाउंट बना सकते हो फ्री अकाउंट एक
बार आपने बना लिया तो उसके बाद 250
रिक्वेस्ट तक आप यूज कर सकते हो उसको देन
उसके बाद चेंज कर लीजिए
हां बिल्कुल सोडा की तरह ही काम करता है
जैसे आपका सडन था वैसे य काम करता है तो
सडन का अल्टरनेट यह है तो इस तरीके यहां
से भी आप इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर सकते हो
लेकिन सडन से कम इंफॉर्मेशन अती अवेलेबल
रहती है इसके पास सडन के पास ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है तो इसको मैं सिंपली
अभी लॉग आउट कर देता हूं सो दैट की हम
नेक्स्ट टूल पर चलते
हैं अभी एक और सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन टूल है
जो मैं आपको बता रहा हूं उसका नाम है उसका
उस का नाम हमारा
है पेन टेस्ट
टूल पेनस टेस्ट टूल्स यह देखिए एक और टूल
अवेलेबल है पेंटेंस टूल्स यह देखिए यह भी
एक सब
डोमेन एमेशन टूल्स है ओके तो य प आप क्या
कर सकते हो फ्री में साइन अप करके
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो मैं आपको
सिर्फ इस टूल का इंट्रोडक्शन दे रहा हूं
आपको बता रहा हूं ये टूल्स आप कर सकते हो
यूज कर सकते हो
चलो पीछे वाला टूल का आपको लिंक
चाहिए क्या फाइंड आउट कर
लोगे फाइंड आउट कर लोगे तो इजी है चलो
इसका लिंक मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं
चलो कंट्रोल सी और आपको इसका लिंक मैं
आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं किसके अंदर
लिंक
के अंदर बहुत सारे फीचर्स अवेलेबल है फॉर
एग्जांपल एग्जांपल ड कॉम की जगह हम य क्या
लिख सकते
हैं फक्ड कॉ कर सकते
हैं
देखिए इट विल टेक टाइम
आज की क्लास के नोट्स का प्रैक्टिकल सेशन
चल रहे हैं मैं सिर्फ आपको टूल्स दिखा रहा
हूं यूज करके यह तो नोट्स ही है आपके
सामने प्रैक्टिकल करना है यार इसमें क्या
नोट्स क्या करोगे मैं आपको टूल का नाम बता
रहा हूं साथ के साथ लिंक प्रोवाइड कर रहा
हूं आप उस लिंक को सेव कर लीजिए और जैसे
ही क्लास खत्म हो जाती है प्रैक्टिस के
लिए
को दोबारा देखिए या साथ के साथ प्रैक्टिस
कीजिए यह सारी चीजें टाइम ले रही है तो आप
आप भी कर सकते हो साथ के साथ क्योंकि मैं
आपको लिंक दे रहा हूं
ना हां यह फ्री है फ्री वाला यूज कर रहे
मतलब जो लाइटर है इसका लाइटर वर्जन फ्री
है उसके बाद आपको इसकी सारी सर्विसेस यूज
करनी है तो आप इसका पेड वर्जन यूज कर सकते
हो बट आपको जरूरत नहीं है पेड वर्जन यूज
करने की क्योंकि मार्केट में और भी बहुत
सारे टूल्स अवेलेबल है
यह देखिए स्कैन फिनिश्ड सब डोमेन आठ सब
डोमेन की लिस्ट इसके सामने मिली है इसको
मिली है देखिए यह रहा वही इंफॉर्मेशन जो
हमने मिली थी xd.com
[संगीत]
academy.com
. de.com wwf.com a कफ de.com आई एड्रेस
के साथ आपको ये इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है अब ये
कितनी सही है कितनी नहीं है आप देख सकते
हो चाहो तो कंट्रोल सी
एंड कंट्रोल
व को 03 फॉर बिन मतलब हो सकता है यह पहले
यूज की गई हो बाद में सर्विस को बंद कर
दिया गया अब एफटीपी सर्विस क्यों यूज की
होगी वेब सर्वर के साथ इसका एक रीजन रहता
है अपकमिंग क्लासेस में हम बताएंगे
यह देखिए
यह
देखिए यह देखिए ज्यादा कुछ नहीं है बट
एग्जांपल ड कॉम होस्टिंगर टाइप आई आई
होस्टिंगर कॉम तो इस तरीके से कुछ है
कन्फेशन पहले किया होगा तो वह वाली बात है
य और कुछ नहीं
है और ऑटो
कंट्रोल
c यह देखिए सेम वही फाइल है उसके बाद आप
चाहो तो यह भी चेक कर सकते हो देखिए
पोर्टल यह
देखिए देखिए यह पोर्टल आ गया आपका समझ पा
एक
पोर्टल जो आपको आउटसाइड से अवेलेबल नहीं
है समझ रहे हो तो इस तरीके से इंफॉर्मेशन
आप गैदर कर सकते हो इन टूल्स की हेल्प से
नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं हम एक और टूल है
चलो मैं इसको अभी बंद कर देता हूं तो आप
इस टूल को खुद ही यूज करके देखिए कि व्ट
टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन आर यू गेटिंग आपको कुछ
वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है या नहीं
मिल रही है वो आप फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
विद द हेल्प ऑफ
डीप स्कैन करोगे उसके लिए पैसे लगेंगे जो
लाइट स्कैन आपका फ्री है इसमें और भी सारी
फ चीजें काम कर सकते उसके साथ देखिए टूल्स
है टूल्स में आप क्या कर सकते हो ग डकिंग
कर सकते हो डोमेन फाइंड कर सकते हो सब
डोमेन फाइंड कर सकते हो वर्चुअल होस्ट
वेबसाइट रिकॉन कर सकते हो फजिंग कर सकते
हो पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर सकते हो इवन व
स्कैनर भी यूज कर सकते हो इनके वेबसाइट
स्कैनर एपीआई स्कैनर वर्डप्रेस स्कैनर तो
यह सारी सर्विसेस आप ले सकते हो इनसे
एक्सप्लोर टूल्स भी अवेलेबल इसके पास ये
ट्राई कर सकते हो अगर आपकी वेबसाइट
वल्नरेबल है तो चलो अभी इसको मैं बंद कर
देता हूं इसका भी लिंक मैंने आपको
प्रोवाइड कर दिया था नेक्स्ट अब बात करते
हैं हम वो है आपका वायरस टोटल वायरस टोटल
के बारे में सब सबने सुना है
ओके यह देखिए हम जाते हैं वायरस टोटल के
ऊपर बेसिकली वायरस टोटल का काम और कुछ है
लेकिन क्या है कि इसके पास भी इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल रहती है तो इसके डेटाबेस में भी
आप सब डोमेन इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग कर सकते हो ओके जैसे यहां पर मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं अभी यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करते हैं ऊपर से रिलेटेड देखिए आप
सिंपली देखो यहां पर आप क्या कर सकते हो
एक बेसिक स्टेप हम मान सकते हैं वायरस
टोटल को लेकर फॉर एग्जांपल आप कोई भी इन
फ्यूचर एज अ साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर आप
जब भी आपको क्या लगता है कोई भी फाइल
डाउनलोड करते हो इंटरनेट से या आपको कुछ
शक है कि यह सॉफ्टवेयर ये टूल्स ये फाइल्स
सारी की सारी कोई मिलिशिया है या नहीं है
तो आपके पास एक सबसे पहला स्टेप अवेलेबल
है आप सिंपली क्या कर सकते हो उस फाइल को
या उस यूआरएल को वायरस टोटल के अंदर स्कैन
करके देख सकते हो फॉर एग्जांपल मेरी एक
फाइल है जिसको मुझे अगर डाउट लग रहा है कि
यह 256 एब तक की फाइल को लोड करके स्कैन
कर सकता है फॉर एपल डॉक्यूमेंट मेरे पास
कोई डॉक्यूमेंट नहीं है डाउनलोड में मेरे
पास कोई डॉक्यूमेंट नहीं है जैसे कि एक ये
एक्सलस फाइल है चलो इसी पर मुझे डाउट है
मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं इसके अंदर यह चेक
करेगा है को फाइल चूज की उसके बाद क्या है
कि टोटल 59 या 70 एंटीवायरस आर अवेलेबल जो
इसको स्कैन करेंगे और कहीं ना कहीं तो
डिटेक्ट होगा ही होगा यह सबसे आपका बेसिक
तरीका है आप अपने आपको को एक बेसिक लेवल
पर पता कर सकते हो कि जो फाइल आप यूज करने
वाले हो अपने सिस्टम के अंदर क्या वह
वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है मैक्सिमम साइज 650
तक की फाइल को आप स्कैन कर सकते हो या कोई
भी मिशिस यूआरएल उठा सकते हो आप यहां पर
चेक कर सकते हो कितने एंटीवायरस के अंदर
मतलब वायरस को दवारा डिटेक्ट किया जा रहा
है
ओके नाउ नेक्स्ट सर्च के अंदर हम क्या कर
सकते हैं यहां पर यहां पर हम सर्च करते
हैं रिलेटेड टू एनी वेबसाइट मैं र वेबसाइट
को ही सर्च करता हूं इसके अंदर भी देखिए
यहां पर भी आपको सब डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल जाएगी अगर अवेलेबल होगी तो
देखिए सर्च करेंगे
हम
ओके सर्च
[संगीत]
और ना दिस इज द डॉक्यूमेंट नाउ सर्च सर्च
सर्च ओके
य क्लीन कर रहा बट दे लॉट ऑफ ग इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल डिटेल्स
रिलेशन यह
देखिए यह सब डोमन की इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही
है देखिए यह रही यहां पर अवेलेबल आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पर य इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने
को मिल जाएगी देर 571 सब डोमेन आर अवेलेबल
अगेन देर आईपी एड्रेस देखिए यह देखिए आप
यहां से इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
रिलेटेड टू योर सब डोम एक और य तरीका आपके
पास टूल का पर्पस और कुछ था और हम इसको
अपने अलग दूसरे परपज से यूज कर सकते हैं
एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर
देखिए य अगर आपको नहीं ता इसको आप सर्च भी
कर सकते हो
देखिए ओपन न्यू
टैब यह अभी य टोटल के थ्रू य इसको ओपन
करेगा बट अदर वाइज हम इसको क्या करते
क्लोज करते हैं इस डोमेन को हम कॉपी करते
हैं
और कॉपी लिंक जस्ट कॉपी करते हैं और यहां
पर पेस्ट करते
हैं यह देखिए र का कोई ना कोई यहां पर पेज
अवेलेबल है तो डोंट वरी ये जस्ट फॉर
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग परपस से मैं आपको दिखा
रहा हूं
देखिए इस तरह के लोग आते हैं जब ग्रुप में
कि एक तिशु राजन कुमार है और एक यह है समद
समद इन तरह के लोग इन तरह लोगों की वजह से
ही क्या ना जो अच्छा खासा काम करने वाले
स्टूडेंट होते हैं ना जिनको म डेडिकेट काम
सीखने के लिए आते हैं वो इनकी वजह से
सीखने के लिए रुक जाते हैं क्योंकि इनको
खुद तो कुछ आता नहीं और दूसरों को कुछ
करने देंगे नहीं ऐसे ही कल जब मैं क्लास
एंड कर रहा था लास्ट क्लास डे थी की वहां
पर भी यही था एक इसी टाइप के जो मिशिस
पीपल बोल सकते हो मैं इनको मसी बोल सकता
हूं जिनको खुद स्पैमिंग के अलावा और कोई
काम नहीं
आता खुद तो दम होता नहीं है सामने आने का
बस नाम बदल के इसके अंदर कुछ बस भेजते र
स्पैम मैसेज क्या फर्क पड़ता है कोई कुछ
तो करने वाला है
नहीं मैं तो अ नहीं वैसे मैं बता रहा हूं
इतना ही दम है तो सामने आओ फिर चलो अभी हम
बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट मैंने आपको बताया पन
टेस्ट टूल के बारे में वाय टोटल के बारे
में अभी हम पढ़ेंगे नेक्स्ट टूल है जो सब
लिस्टर है सब लिस्टर के बारे में पढ़ेंगे
एक और टूल्स है जो सब डोमेन एमेशन के काम
आता है तो उसका गिट अप लिंक्स मैं
आपको बताता हूं सब
लिस्टर यह देखिए यह इसका गिट अप लिंक्स है
मैं आपको शेयर भी कर
दूंगा यह भी एक सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन टूल्स
है यह रहा चलो कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल
व मैं सिर्फ
आपको कल्पना सिंह मैं आपको सिर्फ क्या कर
रहा हूं कि इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करके दिखा
रहा हूं जस्ट फॉर इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इसके
अलावा मैं कुछ भी करके नहीं दिखा रहा आपको
मैं सब आपके सामने क किस तरीके से आप
इफर्म फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन किसी भी
वेबसाइट के बारे में उसके ऊपर मैं
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग अभी नहीं कर रहा ओके
वह हम करना सिखाऊंगा मैं आपको फर्द
अपकमिंग क्लासेस
में वैसे आप चाहो तो कर सकते हो मैं जस्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना सिखा रहा हूं
आपको ओके नाउ अभी इसको इस टूल को अगर मुझे
डाउनलोड करना अपने सिस्टम के अंदर तो मैं
आपको स्टेप बता देता हूं गिट हब से अगर
कोई भी टूल्स हम उसको इंस्टॉल करते हैं
अपने
कोड वाले आइकन पर क्लिक करना है यहां पर
आपको एचटीटीपीएस वाले पर क्या करना है
कॉपी
यूआरएल ओके कॉपी यूआरएल करना है और सिंपली
आपको क्या करना है अ स्क्रीन को मिनिमाइज
करते हैं दिस इज आवर टर्मिनल मैं इसको
टर्मिनल को क्लियर कर लेता हूं एक बार और
क्लियर करने के बाद हम क्या करते हैं गिट
क्लोन करते हैं गिट क्लोन देन कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट v क्लिपबोर्ड को पेस्ट किया और
सिंपली हिट एंटर अभी क्या करेंगे जो सब
लिस्टर की जो गट अब रिपोजिटरी थी उसको
हमने क्या कर लिया अपने
किस परपज से बनाया गया है कैसे इसको यूज
करना है दूसरी एक फाइल है requirement.txt
आपको इसको क्या करना है इसमें क्या है कि
वो सारे डिपेंडेंसीज है टूल से रिलेटेड वो
आप फुलफिल कर सकते हो तीसरा सेटअप ड पाई
इस फाइल को सेटअप करने के लिए कुछ
कॉन्फिडेंस होती है वो भी आप कर सकते हो
सब रूट अवेलेबल है यह आपका टूल की एक्चुअल
कोड अवेलेबल इसके अंदर किसके अंदर पाइथन
के अंदर तो सिंपली हम सबसे पहले क्या
करेंगे सबसे पहले हम क्या करेंगे इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट को फुलफिल करते हैं सुडो
पिप
इंस्टॉल देन उसके बाद हाइन आर देन
रिक्वायरमेंट डटी एक्सटी रिक्वायरमेंट डटी
एक्सटी हिट एंटर करना है और पासवर्ड आपको
दे देना अपनी मशीन का क्योंकि यहां पर रूट
प्रिविलेज चाहिए आपको इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
को फुलफिल करने के लिए क्योंकि आप एक
नॉर्मल यूजर है अभी आपको क्या करना है
प्रिविलेज यूजर बनना है ओके सिंपली हमने
इसको कर लिया देन उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना
है नेक्स्ट जो कमांड रन करनी
है नेक्स्ट कमांड मेरी पिप इंस्टॉल हो गया
ओके एंड देन हम क्या करते हैं सेटअप फाइल
रन करनी है
सुडो पाइथन 3 देन उसके बाद सेटप डट पाई
सेटप डट पाई उसके बाद उसको क्या करना है
इंस्टॉल करना है यह कमांड भी सक्सेसफुली
आपको क्या करनी है रन करनी है अपनी मशीन
के अंदर इंस्टॉल
हिट
एंटर नाउ हमने सक्सेसफुली इसको सेट फाइल
को भी रन कर लिया देन उसके बाद अब हम
देखते हैं टूल को कैसे यूज करना है तो टूल
को यूज करने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे पाइथन
उसके बाद क्या है सब लिस्टर सब लिस्टर डॉट
पाई सब लिस्टर डॉट पाई य उसके पाइथन 3
पाइथन 3 उसके बाद सबलिस्ट ड
पाई हान हान अब मैं सीधा एंटर करता हूं तो
इसकी यूसेज फाइल देखते हैं कैसे इसको यूज
कर सकते हैं देखिए अब यह सब लिस्टर है य
आपको क्या यूज करना पाइथन सब लिस्टर ड पाई
य पर ऑप्शन मेंशन करने हैं यूज हाइन एच
फॉर हेल्प अगर मुझे हेल्प मेनू चाहिए तो
देखिए हाइन एच
ओके अभी आपको दिखाई दे रहा है कि आप क्या
क्या ऑप्शन यूज कर सकते हो हाइन डी डोमेन
हाइ फन बी अगर आपको क्या करना है ब्रूट
फोर्स करना है ब्रूट फोर्स कब करते हो फॉर
एग्जांपल आपने अपने स्कोप को एक्सटेंड
करना है आपने एक इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की अब
उस डोमेन के ऊपर और भी अगर कोई नया डोमेन
आया होगा तो आपके पास क्या है एक प्री
डिफाइंड वर्ड लिस्ट है उस वर्ड लिस्ट का
यूज करके आप क्या कर सकते हो उसके ऊपर
ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हो अब ब्रूट फोर्स जब
आप किसी भी डोमेन के ऊपर या किसी भी सब
डोमेन के ऊपर करोगे तो आप क्या करते हो
उसके साथ फिर एक्टिवली इंगेज करने लग जाते
हो एक्टिवली इंगेज करने लग जाते हो तो अभी
जो हमारा पार्ट है वो क्या है एक्टिवली
इंगेज नहीं करना है हमें सिर्फ क्या है कि
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना है
एक्टिवली इंगेज करने के लिए आप क्या कर
सकते हो जैसे फजिंग कर सकते हो डायरेक्टरी
सर्च कर सकते हो तो बहुत सारे टूल्स होते
हैं जो एक्टिवली इंगेज करने के लिए काम
आते हैं लेकिन अभी मैं पैसिव इंगेज कर रहा
हूं इसलिए मैं इस बट फोर्सिंग करके नहीं
दिखाऊंगा लेकिन अगर आप चाहोगे तो मैं एक
बार एक कमांड आपके सामने शो कर दूंगा किस
तरीके से आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो देन उसके
बाद मुझे क्या करना फॉर एग्जांपल अभी इसको
यूज करना है यूसेज क्या है किय रहा पान 3
सबलिस्ट हाड पाई उसके बाद हाइन डी मैं यूज
करू डोमेन नेम किस डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन
चाहिए मुझे अभी मुझे चाहिए जैसे
कि या चाहिए मुझे याड कॉ चाहिए
मुझे याड कॉ ही चाहिए चलो हिट एंटर कर
देता हूं
देखिए अभी यह क्या कर रहा है बेड य ट्रस
पास पाइथन बप नॉट ओके ओके कुछ
दे ओके अभी ये फाइंड आउट कर रहा है कहीं
कुछ लाइंस में या किसी टूल से टे डीएनएस
डमर वाले कोड में कुछ इश्यूज है उसको हमें
रिजॉल्व करना होगा डोंट वरी दे अदर जो
सर्च इंजन है बेडू याहू ग बिंग आस्क वायस
टोटल या ए तो उनके थ्रू भी क्या कर रहा है
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करने की कोशिश कर रहा
है कि कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है नहीं
है
इट विल टेक
टाइम अब वाय टोटल क्या कर रहा है इसको
ब्लॉक कर रहा है तो इट्स ओके दे अदर ऑप्शन
आर
अवेलेबल बहुत सारी बुक्स अवेलेबल है वैसे
मार्केट में आपको भी पढ़ सकते हो तो अगर
वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड आपको पढ़ना है तो
हैकर्स हैंड बुक है जो वेबसाइट के ऊपर
ओनली व भी पढ़ सकते हो या किसी ओनली हर एक
मतलब अगर एंड्र में पढ़ना तो हैकर हैंड
बुक फॉर एंड्राइड के लिए अलग से अवेलेबल
है और बाकी तो इंटरनेट पर आजकल सबसे
बढ़िया मुझे अच्छी चीज बताओ क्या लगी आप
बुक्स की बजाय अगर आप क्या करोगे मीडियम
की हेल्प लोगे मीडियम पर देर लॉट ऑफ
आर्टिकल्स आर अवेलेबल एंड ट्राई हैक मी पर
दे लॉट ऑफ टिकल्स या एक रोड मैप में एक
लर्निंग पाथ है उसको फॉलो करोगे तो ये
सारी चीज काफी एनफ आपके लिए क्योंकि आपने
अगर बेसिक ग्रेजुएशन करते हो आप बीसीए या
कंप्यूटर साइंस में करते हो तो आपका
फंडामेंटल क्रिएट कर देता है और जब उसे
फोकस करना आपको साइबर सिक्योरिटी में आपके
पास ट्राई हैक में हैक द बस है बॉक्स है
देन उसके बाद क्या कर सकते हो कोर्सेस में
पढ़िए ध्यान से और जो जो टॉपिक आपके सामने
है या टॉपिक में जो टूल्स यूज हो रहे हैं
या टॉपिक कि कोई पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक है या
किसी पटे का अटैक है तो उससे रिलेटेड
रिसर्च करके अपने पास नोट्स बनाओगे तो
उससे अच्छी बुक कोई नहीं
है मतलब कुछ इशू आ रहा है फॉर एग्जांपल
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं सब रूट उसके बाद
मैं हाइन ई का यूज कर सकता हूं हाइन ई
मतलब मैं किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्च इंजन से ही
क्या करना चाहता हूं सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन
करना चाहता हूं मैं यूज करूंगा ग ग से
चाहता हूं नेक्स्ट हान व यूज सता वर्बोस
आउटपुट के लिए क्या हो रहा है यह
देखिए वर्बोसिटी इ इनेबल मतलब कि अब आपके
टर्मिनल में हो क्या रहा है य टूल कैसे
काम कर रहा है क्या क्या चीज कर रहा है तो
सारी चीज आपके वर्सिटी में शो करेगा य य
ना सर्चिंग मतलब य कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन अभी
शो नहीं कर रहा या से रिलेटेड फ एपल
इंफॉर्मेशन बदल के देख लेते हैं अभी
रिलेटेड
टू या मे बी सम कॉन्फिन एरर तो वो हमें
रिजॉल्व करनी होगी फिर क्योंकि मैं काफी
टाइम बाद आपके सामने परफॉर्म करके दिखा
रहा हूं तो मे
भी हो सकती है डे
फोनिक्स ओके डोमेन वैलिड
इनवैलिड ओके थैंक यू कोली
नाउ अभी शो नहीं कर रहा मे बी सम इशू विद
दैट ओके टूल्स में कुछ एरर्स है मे बी यह
हमें रिजॉल्व करनी
होगी हां सब कुछ होगा राजू टेक टाइम हर एक
चीज पर हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप जाएंगे
लिनक्स इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग क्या होता है
नक्स तो एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है अब आप
आउटसाइड से ऑपरेट कर रहे हो तो आपको तो
पहले पता करना होगा ना कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम यूज किया रहा
है न ट लेकिन अटैक करेंगे तो हम लिनक्स के
ऊपर क्या करें नक् प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कर
लिनक्स हैकिंग जिसको हम बोलते हैं कि अगर
आपको पता चल गया कि बिहाइंड सिस्टम इसके
पीछे नक्स है तो लिनक्स को आप हैक कैसे कर
सकते हो रूट प्रिविलेजेस कैसे लोगे तो वो
मैं आपको
बताऊंगा मे भी सम एरर विद सम प्रॉब्लम विद
सब रूट हमें इसको चेक करना पड़ेगा इसके
अंदर कुछ और भी इशू हो सकते हैं
फल अभी इसको हम यूज करके देख लेते हैं ऐसे
ही
नहीं काली में पहले से कहां आता है नहीं
आता
इसको हमेशा इंस्टॉल करना पड़ता
है चलो भै आपके लिए हम क्या कर
लेंगे आपकी खुशी के लिए भी कर देते हैं
ओके चलो शायद आने लग गया
ओके थैंक यू जिसने बताया मेरे
को दिस इज न्यू फॉर मी एंड नाउ सब
लिस्टर ओके हाइन
एच चलो अभी हम यूज करके देखते हैं चलो कोई
इशू नहीं है तो थैंक यू सबलिस्ट हाई फन
चलो मैं आपके सामने अभी इसको स्क्रीन को
जूम कर देता हूं और
छोटे कर देते पहले सामने आपके सामने इसको
हम चलो अभी हम इसको यूज करके देखते
हैं पहले वाले को हम बंद कर देते हैं
अभी भाई क्या
गया ओके चलो बैक
मिनिमाइज मैं तुम्हें छोटा सा
सबलिस्ट हाइ फन क्या था
डी डोमेन उसके बाद
याहू ड
कॉ ओके हिट एंटर करते
हैं सेम इशू
तो वी नीड टू रिजॉल्व द
एरर कोई मेरे साथ में काम कर रहा
है कोई भी
तो अबे आपकी मेर आ रही
है साइबर मुझे भी पता है यार कि कहां पर
चेक करना बड़ अभी हमारे पास टाइम नहीं है
इतना किर को हम सॉल्व करेंगे बट नो इशू आप
इसको यूज कर सकते हो यह वही
होगी यह
रहा ओके साइन इन करना पड़ेगा मुझे इसके
लिए और मेरे पास अभी क्रेडेंशियल मुझे याद
नहीं
है तो इसके ऊपर हम बाद में डिस्कशन कर
सकते हैं आप खुद से कर सकते हैं
उसको आपको कमांड्स में बता सकता हूं इसको
कैसे आपको यूज करनी है मेरे
पास आईडिया लग गया होगा कैसे यूज करना है
इसको बेसिकली कि आपको सब लिस्टर की आपके
पास हेल्प है जैसे कि कुछ कमांड्स मैं
आपको बता देता हूं जो आप मोस्टली यूज कर
सकते हो जो मोस्ट पावरफुल कमांड्स होती है
इसमें कि इसके केस में यूज की जाने वाली
जैसे कि मैं आपको जूम करके दिखा देता हूं
क्लियर कर देता
हूं एक तो हम यूज करेंगे
मैं सब लिस्टर
अरे वेट
चलो एक काम करते हैं हम नेक्स्ट टूल के
ऊपर बात करते हैं इसको हम फिर बाद बाद में
कर सकते हैं सब लिस्टर को कैसे यूज करना
है वैसे तो आप खुद भी कर लोगे तो अदर वाइज
मैं आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास में दिखा दूंगा सब
लिस्टर को कैसे यूज करना है इसके एरर को
रिजॉल्व करके नेक्स्ट टूल की बात हम करते
हैं अभी आ जाते हैं एक टूल्स और है
एकय
[संगीत]
रहा सी एच चा
होस य
रहा
चास नो नो नो इसकी मे पास कंप्लीट करना
पड़ेगा
एटीपीएस एक प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी एक
प्रोजेक्ट
है सी
एच एओ एस डॉट
आया यह
रहा यह एक प्रोजेक्ट है एक चाउस ड
प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी डट
आयो यहां पर क्या है आपको जितने भी बग
बाउंट प्रोग्राम चलते हैं और उनके अंदर
जितने भी प्रोग्राम्स अपलोडेड है जिन जिन
जिन जिन वेबसाइट के ऊपर आप हंट कर सकते हो
उनके लिस्ट अवेलेबल है उनके सब डोमेन
अवेलेबल है और यह क्या करता है ऑटोमेटिक
स्कैन करता रहता है कि दो घंटे पहले स्कैन
किया था पा घंटे पहले स्कैन किया था उसके
पास इंफॉर्मेशन कौन से नए सब डोमेन ऐड हुए
हैं यस बिल्कुल
प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी की तरफ से यहां पर आप
देख सकते हो देखिए यहां पर आप देख सकते
हो प्लेटफॉर्म के हिसाब से
और यह रहा बहुत सा डाटा अवेलेबल य पर यह
रहा सब डोमेन के हिसाब से यह देखो अपडेटेड
14 आवर्स एगो देखिए जूम सब
डोमेन दे टोटल 46 न्यू वन एंड प्लेटफॉर्म
के अकॉर्डिंग आप चेक कर सकते हो जैसे
अकॉर्डिंग टू प्लेटफॉर्म भी आप सर्च कर
सकते हो यहां पर अभी हम देख सकते हैं
जैसे मैं u के फॉर एग्जांपल मैं सर्च करना
चाहता हूं
र
देखिए र रिलेटेड अवेलेबल है यह देखो
प्लेटफॉर्म हैकर वन पे इसका प्रोग्राम
चलता है और आप चाहो तो इसको क्या कर सकते
हो डाउनलोड कर सकते हो जैसे मैं इसको
डाउनलोड करूंगा देर
9955 सब डोमेन आर अवेलेबल जैसे मैं इसको
ओपन करता हूं देखिए फाइल को जैसे इसको मैं
अनजिप करता हूं एक्सट्रैक्ट
हियर एक्स्टेक्स्ट
हियर यह
रहा यह सब डोमेन की लिस्ट है र के जितने
भी है यह र्स के सब डोमेन की लिस्ट है यह
मेंटेन करके रखते हैं आपके सामने देखने को
मिलेगी ओके दूसरा एक और चीज है कि हम इसके
थ्रू ऑटोमेटिक कैसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर
सकते देखो यह तो क्या है ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस है ठीक है ये आपका ग्राफिकल है
अगर हम चाहे तो क्या कर सकते हैं किसी को
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस पसंद नहीं है जो
सीएल आई के थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना
चाहता है सील के थ्रू य सब डोमेन एमेशन
करना चाहता है व भी कर सकता है काफी
हेल्पफुल प्लेटफॉर्म है यहां पर आप चाहते
हो किसी भी प्रोग्राम के हिसाब से ब बटी
प्रोग्राम जैसे किकर वन है बग क्राउड है
या जो
भी प्रोग्राम्स अवेलेबल है देखि आप देख
सकते हो इंटीग्रिटी है हैक एंड प्रूफ है
या सेल्फ होस्टेड है मतलब सब हर एक उसके
प्लेटफॉर्म के अकॉर्डिंग यहां पर क्या है
जो भी वेबसाइट रजिस्टर्ड है जो भी जिसने
भी जिसी भी वेबसाइट का क्या है प्रोग्राम
चलता है बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम चलता है तो
उनकी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अंदर इस
डेटाबेस के अंदर है और इस डेटाबेस के
अकॉर्डिंग आप क्या कर सकते हो अपडेट भी रह
सकते हो कि कोई नया डोमेन तो सब डोमेन तो
ऐड नहीं हुआ है कंपनी प्रोग्राम में ओके
तो चाहो तो आप एक काम कर सकते हो सीएल आई
भी यूज कर सकते हो सील आई यूज करने के लिए
आपको यूज करना होगा एक गिट हब रिपोजिटरी
है उस वो रिपोजिटरी है है गब
कॉ यह है आपका एक मिनट ऐसे नहीं ऐसे तो इट
विल टेक टाइम सी एच ए ओ एस
पाई चास पाई य रहा गिट
हब दिस
वन मे बी
हम हम हम
यह
वाला आप यहां पर इसको क्या कर सकते हो
अपने ट अपने काली नेक्स के
अंदर इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं इसको कैसे
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो इसको भी सिंपली आपके
ऑप्शंस है नीचे स्कैन करोगे देखो टूल
रिटर्न रिटर्न ऑन चास फम प्रव आ टोटली
पाइथन में लिखा गया है इंस्टॉल करने का
तरीका गिट क्लोन करना है
स्पाई डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जाना है इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट को इंस्टॉल करना है यह इसके
यूसेज है और इस तरीके से आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हो अभी हम इसको यूज कैसे करेंगे
देखिए मैं सिंपली क्या करता है
इसको गिट क्लोन नाउ ओपन आवर टर्मिनल
हम यहां पर अपने टर्मिनल को ओपन करते हैं
और यह
रहा गिट
क्लोन यह
रहा सिंपली एलएस ये रहा इसकी एक
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट हो गई होगी चाउस पाई तो
हम क्या करते हैं सीडी करते हैं चाउस पाई
हिट एंटर एलस करते हैं रिक्वायरमेंट डटी
एक्सटी फाइल को फुलफिल करते हैं तो
सुडो
पिप
इंस्टॉल सुडो पिप इंस्टॉल रिक्वायरमेंट
डटी
एक्सटी हिट
एंटर ओके अभी सही दिखाई दे रहा है सबको
चाउस में उन सब डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती
है बेसिकली आप क्या करते हो आप भी बग
बाउंट
प्रोग्राम बग बाउंट के लिए क्या करते हो
आप बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम पर जाते हो वहां से
सब डोमेन या वेबसाइट चूज करते हो और अपना
बग बाउंट स्टार्ट कर देते हो तो उनसे
रिलेटेड ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन इधर भी मिल
जाती है अगर आपके पास कुछ ऐसा कोई
प्रोजेक्ट है ऐसा कोई टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
जो आपका बग बाउंडी प्रोग्राम में नहीं है
लेकिन एक प्राइवेट ऑर्गे उससे रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन इसके ऊपर नहीं
मिलेगी ओके अभी हम क्या करते हैं इसको यूज
करेंगे अभी एलएस रिक्वायरमेंट फुलफिल होगी
अभी इसको यूज करने का तरीका है
पाइथन थ उसके बाद चास पाई उसके बाद हाइन
है हाइन एच हेल्प तो इसको यूज करने का
तरीका देखिए हाइन एच लिस्ट है लिस्ट द
प्रोग्राम्स हा फन हा फन लिस्ट लिस्ट ओनली
बग क्राउड प्रोग्राम्स लिस्ट हैकर वन
लिस्ट ओनली हैकर वन प्रोग्राम्स लिस्ट
ओनली इंटीग्रिटी प्रोग्राम्स लिस्ट ओनली
सेल्फ होस्टड प्रोग्राम्स लिस्ट ओनली
स्वक्स ऑफर्स लिस्ट ओनली रिवार्ड्स तो ये
सारी चीजें आप उसके बाद क्या यू कैन
डाउनलोड सेल्फ स्पेसिफिक प्रोग्राम यू कैन
डाउनलोड ऑल द प्रोग्राम्स या यू कैन
डाउनलोड ओनली बक क्राउड प्रोग्राम्स यू
कैन डाउनलोड ओनली हैकर वन प्रोग्राम्स या
यू कैन डाउनलोड ओनली इंटीग्रेट
प्रोग्राम्स इस तरीके से आप इसको यूज कर
सकते फर एपल अगर मैं लिस्ट देखना चाहता
हूं कौन-कौन से प्रोग्राम इसके परर
रजिस्टर है तो हम कैसे देख सकते हैं
देखिए
पाइथन हाइन एल देखिए इसके लिए हाइन एल यूज
कर सकते हैं उसके बाद हाइन लिस्ट भी यूज
कर सकते हैं आप चाहो तो हाइन लिस्ट ही कर
देते हैं
लिए यह सारी लिस्ट शो करेगा जितने भी
प्रोग्राम्स इसके ऊपर रजिस्टर्ड है ब सॉरी
बग बाउटी बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म के अंदर
ऊपर यह देखिए
यह सारे के सारे प्रोग्राम्स आप मतलब
कितनी बड़ी लिस्ट होगी यह बहुत ज्यादा
बड़ी लिस्ट होगी अगर डायरेक्टली देखना
चाहते हो तो आपको बता देता हूं डायरेक्टली
यह
रहा सिंपली पाइथन 3 चास पाई इसको एंटर
कीजिए और आपके एक सिंपल आईडिया मिल जाएगा
कि किस प्लेटफार्म के ऊपर कितने सब डोमस
है देखिए यहां पर टोटल इतने सब डोमन देखिए
795 टोटल प्रोग्राम्स है 89 प्रोग्राम
चेंज हो चुके हैं कोई भी नया प्रोग्राम
नहीं है हैकर वन के पास 332 प्रोग्राम्स
है 12 इंटीग्रिटी के पास है 100 बग क्राउड
के पास है 217 सेल होस्टेड प्रोग्राम्स है
529 प्रोग्राम विद रिवार्ड्स है 27
प्रोग्राम ऑफर स्वग्स है 266 नॉट रिवर्ड
प्रोग्राम्स है तो ये इंफॉर्मेशन एक बेसिक
आईडी इंफॉर्मेशन है अगर मैं इसके अंदर
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल
हाइन मेरे पास थी डी अग मैं नडी के साथ
यूज करना चाहूं इसको और उसके बाद मैं u से
रिलेटेड इमेशन फाइंड आट करना चाहता हूं
देखिए ब का कोई प्रोग्राम अवेलेबल है या
नहीं यस देखिए अभी फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करेगा ये नो लेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन बता
नहीं रहा एक मिनट एक मिनट मुझे हेल्प फाइल
चाहिए
इधर ओके
सॉरी नाउ अभी मुझे क्या करना होगा अभी
मुझे क्या करना होगा डी डाउनलोड स्पेसिफिक
प्रोग्राम डाउनलोड ऑल प्रोग्राम तो मैं
क्या करूंगा जो मैटो से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकता हूं या
किससे टेड मैं फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी इसके अंदर मैं क्या कर सकता
हूं डाउनलोड कर सकता
हूं अरे ओके हाई
फन डाउनलोड फॉर एग्जांपल मैं एक प्रोग्राम
देखना चाहता हूं किसका देखें एल का देखते
हैं डेफिनेटली होगा देखिए
यहां से आप डाउनलोड भी कर सकते
हो अभी यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को
मिल नहीं रही है ज्यादा या मैं एक काम
करता हूं अभी या तो इस पर कुछ काम चल रहा
है देखिए अगर मैं एक काम करते इसको फिर से
हम हेल फाइल ओपन करते हैं तो लास्ट टाइम
मैंने इसको यूज किया था तो काफी कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन चलती थी अभी लास्ट अपडेटेड
दिखा रहा है ये
2024 कोई दिखा रहा है
या अगर मैं क्या हूं डाउनलोड न्यू
प्रोग्राम अगर मैं इसको डाउनलोड न्यू
प्रोग्राम करना चाहता हूं देखिए मैं इसको
हाफ आईन डाउनलोड
न्यू कॉपी सिलेक्शन और
सिंपली इट
ऑल प्रोग्राम सक्सेसफुली डाउनलोडेड एलस
करते हैं
देखिए तो कहां पर डाउनलोड
किए हेल्प फाइल देखनी होगी हमें कहां पर
अभी कुछ चेंज तो नहीं किया इन्होंने
[संगीत]
एक काम करते हैं थोड़ा बैक चलते हैं हम
नो
अगर मैं एक काम करना चाहता हूं चलो एक और
कंड रन करके देखते हैं हैकर वन के जितने
प्रोग्राम उनको यूज करके देखते हैं
बार ओके ओके
देखिए यह हैकर वन प्रोग्राम से फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं इसमें चेक करना चाहता
हूं यह रहा मैं चलो टिकटक को चेक कर ले ता
इस अंदर लिस्ट में शो है या नहीं है फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं अभी टिकटक को सर्च करते चलो
कैसे करते
हम इसको सर्च करने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे
उसके बाद डाउनलोड चलो ओनली इसी का डाउनलोड
करना डाउनलो स्पेसिफिक
प्रोग्राम कॉपी ओ
हो
चलो चलो कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व उसके बाद टिकटक
था हमारा
चलो यह कर लेते हैं हम जन
डेस्क हिट
एंटर य देखो डाउनलोड सक्सेसफुली ओके
प्रोग्राम फाउंड डाउनलोडिंग जनस ओके एलस
इस तरीके से डाउनलोड कर दिया इसने यरी जज
फाइल है इसको मैं अनजिप कर सकता हूं
डायरेक्टली अय काम कर सकता इधर कर लेंगे
गो टू यो होम डायरेक्टरी नान
एंड साउस
सास नो नो नो नो नो नो दिस वन साउस पाई
अभी यह तो इमेज पीएनजी रिक्वायरमेंट य ज
इसको हम क्या करते हैं अभी एक्सक कर देते
हैं यर ना यह रही जन
डेस्क य रहा ज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ ऑल द सब
डोमेन स्ड आ वेब लोडर ये क्या
है ओके देन और भी इसमें इंफॉर्मेशन मिली
होगी गो बैक क्लोज कर देते इसको हम और
क्या
था जनक्स रिलेटेड सारे डोमेन सब डोमेन
इंफॉर्मेशन सारी एक फाइल के अंदर इसने सेव
करके दे दी आपके सामने ओके तो इस तरीके से
आप क्या कर सकते हो पर्टिकुलर जो टारगेट
है आपका जो भी पर्टिकुलर टारगेट सब डोमेन
है डोमेन है उससे रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन आप
इस टूल की हेल्प से भी गैदर कर सकते हो
एवरीवन गोट क्लियर कि आप कैसे कर सकते हो
हो सकता है वो प्रोग्राम इसमें शो नहीं कर
रहा हो इसके डेटाबेस में स्क्रोल नहीं
होगा क्रॉल नहीं हुआ होगा लेकिन इस तरीके
से आप क्या कर सकते हो इस टूल को भी यूज
कर सकते होय काफी हेल्पफुल टूल हो सकता है
कई बार क्या है कि बहुत सारे नए
प्रोग्राम्स आते हैं बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स
में कई नए सब डोमेन ऐड होते हैं लेकिन
आपको नहीं पता नहीं पता रहता आप आप क्या
कर सकते हो कि ऐसे जब भी आप बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम करने के लिए बैठते हो या कोई भी
पेन टेस्टिंग करने बैठते हो और आपका कोई
स्पेसिफिक टारगेट है तो उससे पहले जस्ट
आपको एक मिनट लगेगी उ उस रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन आप इस पे फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
अगर वो प्रोग्राम आपका इसके अंदर है
प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी प्रोग्राम के अंदर है
तो या आपका बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म पर
अवेलेबल है तो ओके तो एवरीवन गट क्लियर
अबाउट दिस टूल मुझे लगता है कि बहुत सारे
लोगों के लिए एक नया टूल होगा यह बहुत
लोगों को नहीं पता होगा इसके बारे में
कितने लोग जानते थे इस टूल के बारे
में गाइस जस्ट अ सेक
नेक्स्ट टूल के बारे में बात करें
अभी टोटल 50 रह ग
यार चलो अच्छी बात है जिसको इस टूल्स के
बारे में सीखने को मिला अच्छी बात है
एंड तो नेक्स्ट टूल के बारे में बात करते
हैं देखो अभी मैं दो मिनट के लिए चैट नहीं
देखूंगा आप लोगों की व काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
और काफी इंपोर्टेंट टूल्स है उसके बारे
में मैं आपको बता देता हूं देखिए जिस आपके
स्क्रीन के सामने देखिए एक बार अभी मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं यह
रहा नेक्स्ट टूल
आपका इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं अभी के
लिए इसको भी क्लोज कर देता हूं
क्लोज क्लोज
क्लोज आपने सुना होगा वे बैक यूआरएल के
बारे
में आर्काइव
ओजी य मिलियंस ऑफ वेबसाइट आ रनिंग अब जहां
पर मिलियंस या बिलियंस ऑफ वेबसाइट जब रन
करती है तो वहां पर डेफिनेटली एक चीज तो
है कि वहां पर इंटरनेट क्रॉलर तो होगा ही
होगा ठीक है वो क्या कर रहा होगा
कंटीन्यूअसली इन सारी वेबसाइट को क्रॉल कर
रहा है जब भी आप किसी भी वेबसाइट को सर्च
करते हो तो तब भी वह कंटीन्यूअसली क्या
करता रहता है क्रॉल करता रहता है अभी
कॉलर्स क्या होता है और कॉलर्स कैसे काम
करता है यह सारी चीजें मैं आपको क्या कर
डे टू की जो क्लास थी उसमें आपको पढ़ा
चुका हूं अभी सबसे बड़ा जो एग्जांपल है
क्रॉलर का वो यह आपके सामने है इंटरनेट
आर्काइव वे बैक मशीन दिस इ द बिगेस्ट
क्रॉलर हु क्रोल मोर देन 866 बिलियन वेब
पेजेस ऑन द इंटरनेट ओके एंड एक सवाल आपके
मन में होगा सर कि ओके यह क्रॉलर है इसके
पास एक डेटाबेस है
लेकिन हम इसके बारे में क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं
हम इसका यूज करेंगे वह सारे यूआरएल की फ
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए जो हमारे टारगेट से
रिलेटेड है ओके जो हमारे टारगेट से
रिलेटेड है और उन यूल्स के अंदर आप क्या
करोगे वनटी फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करोगे
और जब आप उन यूआरएल के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करोगे तो हो सकता है वहां
पर बहुत सारे ऐसे पैरामीटर्स आपको देखने
को मिलेंगे जो आपने अभी तक इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के दौरान या आपने कितने भी डीप
रिकन की हो वह आपको देखने को ना मिले हो
और उनमें से एक और चीज है कि हो सकता है
कि बहुत सारी
यूआरएल डेड हो या चेंज हो गए होंगे लेकिन
बहुत सारे उनमें से एक्टिव भी मिलेंगे और
रनिंग भी मिलेंगे और वहां पर चांसेस हो
जाते हैं कई बार आपको पहले से जो
एजिस्टिफाई
भी कीवर्ड रखिए मैं अभी बात करता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल apple.com
apple.com की बात करता हूं मैं एल की
वेबसाइट कॉ के बारे में बात करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल देखिए जैसे मैंने इसके अंदर सर्च
किया यह आपको इसके डेटाबेस में जो
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है सिंस 2001 से लेके
2000 पहले से ही है यह रहा सिंस 1996 से
लेके और सिंस 2024 तक जितना भी डाटा इसने
क्रॉल किया है रिलेटेड टू दिस वेबसाइट
रिलेटेड टू दिस apple.com वह सारा आपके
सामने है और यह सारे क्या है देखिए
स्क्रीन शट मिलि फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी बात
करता हूं 2014 के डटा की 2014 में सारे जो
ब्लू या ग्रीन सर्कल आपको देखने को मिल
रहे हैं तो इसने क्या किया उस टाइम स्टैंप
पे उस वेबसाइट के स्क्रीनशॉट लिए हुए हैं
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के साथ जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल दे 54 स्नैपशॉट ऑन 14 फरवरी
2014 8:2 पर स्क्रीनशॉट पर क्लिक करता हूं
तो किस तरीके से वेबसाइट किस तरह की
वेबसाइट आपको देखने को मिलती थी उस टाइम
पर 2014 में एल की वेबसाइट
तो इस तरीके से यहां पर बहुत ज्यादा डाटा
आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
देखिए यह इस तरीके से दिखती थी उस टाइम पर
वेबसाइट देखिए उस डेट को मैं इसको जो
स्क्रोल डाउन कर रहा हूं तो अभी आप बस एक
ही पेज है इसने जो कैप्चर किया फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं अभी नेक्स्ट बात करता हूं
यहां पर क्लिक कर देता हूं
देखिए 15 फरवरी 2014 को भी अपली इस तरीके
से दिखाई देती थी चलो अभी हम गो बैक टू
योर वे बैक यूरल फिर से चलते हैं हम चलो
गो बैक ओके अभी यहां पर एक और चीज है यहां
पर आप समरी देख सकते हो यहां पर देखो समरी
समरी टैब में जाओगे तो यहां पर आपको और भी
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल देखिए कि कितने
स्क्रीनशॉट इसने कैप्चर किए हैं कितने
यूनिक यूआरएल है इमेजेस कितनी मिली है
पीएनजी एक्सएमएल जो भी डाटा टेक्स्ट
फाइल्स ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसके पास
अवेलेबल है जसे सारी समध इसके पास देखिए
कैप्चर कितने एचटीएमएल टेक्स्ट शॉर्ट लिए
हैं उसके बाद यह देखिए इमेज जेपीजी के
कैप्चर किए हुए हैं यह एक मतलब प्रेसा एक
बहुत ही शानदार तरीके से आपके सामने
इंफॉर्मेशन इसने रिप्रेजेंट की है देखिए
इस तरीके से कितने न्यू यूआरएल इसके अंदर
ऐड हुए हैं पहले ओल्ड यूआरएल थे उसके बाद
ये देखिए इमेजेस न्यू रल्स न्यू कैप्चर
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल
रही है आप देखोगे तो यहां पर यूआरएल देखो
य यूआरएल पर आप क्लिक करोगे यहां पर
यूआरएल से रिलेटेड भी इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी
वह सारे यूआरएल आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
यहां पर सारे के सारे यूआरएल इससे रिलेटेड
जो 1996 से लेके और अभी तक 2024
तक ये सारी पैस में है अभी तक आपने पैसू
करो क्योंकि आप अभी तक इंटरेक्ट नहीं कर
रहे क्योंकि ये सारा ऑलरेडी डेटाबेस
अवेलेबल है आपने अभी तक टारगेट साथ टारगेट
के साथ इंटरेक्ट किया ही नहीं है क्योंकि
जो इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है इंटरनेट के ऊपर
आप उसी को यूज कर रहे हो एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में तो हम एंटर करेंगे
कि एक्टिवली इंगेज करोगे आप उसके साथ
देखिए इतने सारे यूआरएल हैं देखिए अगर मैं
इसको जूम करूं आपके सामने देखो आपको दिखाई
भी नहीं दे रहे होंगे ये रहा
http.com कब की बात है जून 8 2021 में अगर
मैं इसको क्लिक करते हैं
देखिए पेज नॉट फाउंड एल बट कुछ तो था यहां
पर उस टाइम
पे
ओके देखिए इस तरीके
से तो अभी नेक्स्ट सवाल आपके सामने होगा
बो सर ठीक है हम वे जो इंटरनेट आर्काइव है
उसकी हेल्प से किसी भी वेबसाइट के बारे
में किसी भी टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बारे
में उसकी जो वेबसाइट है ओल्ड से ओल्ड
इंफॉर्मेशन हम देख सकते हैं उसके यूआरएल
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं लेकिन सर हम उसको
डाउनलोड कैसे करेंगे क्या एक एक यूआरएल को
मैं कैप्चर करूंगा देखो पहली बात तो यस कि
अगर आपको सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए
सेंसिटिव टारगेट चाहिए तो यस हर एक यूआरएल
को आपको क्या करना
होगा यूज करके देखना होगा हो सकता है कि
वो अभी एजिस्ट करता है नहीं करता ठीक है
एक तो ये मैनुअल तरीका है ऑटोमेशन तरीका
होता है जब डीप रिकॉन सेक्शन जिसको बोलते
हैं उसमें आप क्या कर सकते हो टूल्स की
हेल्प से भी चेक कर सकते कौन एक्टिव है
कौन डेड है बट मैं भी वो करके दिखाने वाला
नहीं हूं तो एक तो तरीका है दूसरा इन सारे
ल्स की लिस्ट मैं अपने पास कैसे एक फाइल
के अंदर सेव कर सकता हूं ये भी ऑटोमेशन
चाहिए ना आपको एक मैनुअल की बज आपको
ऑटोमेशन चाहिए कि सर मैं मैनुअली इसको कट
कॉपी पेस्ट करने की बजाय अगर मैं सारी की
सारी चीज को अपनी फाइल के अंदर डाउनलोड
करना चाहूं तो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
एवरीवन
वांट आप लोगों के मन में एक और सवाल होगा
सर यह काम तो हम बड बब सूट की हेल्प से भी
तो कर सकते हैं ना तो भैया बात ऐसी है कि
ओके जो बब स्पाइडर है वो कर सकता है लेकिन
बब स्पाइडर उन उस इंफॉर्मेशन को या उन एंड
पॉइंट्स को कैप्चर नहीं कर सकता जो पास्ट
में थे जो करंट एंड पॉइंट्स है उनको आप
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ बर्ब स्पाइडर से आप क्या
कर सकते हो फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो लेकिन आप
जो पास्ट में एक साल पहले 6 महीने पहले या
10 साल पहले 20 साल पहले जो सब डोमस जो
एंड पॉइंट्स यूज किए जा रहे थे वेबसाइट के
ऊपर वो इंफॉर्मेशन आप कैप्चर नहीं कर सकते
किसकी हेल्प से बब स्पाइडर की हेल्प से
ओके देखो अभी मैं वो टूल बताने जा रहा हूं
जिसकी हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो इस
प्रोसेस को बहुत ही इजी बना सकते हो मुझे
नहीं पता आपको पहले से पता है या नहीं पता
है तो मैं सिंपली यूज करने वाला हूं टॉम
नोम का एक य यूआरएल ओके किसकिसको पता
है तो हम उसको यूज करने वाले हैं अभी एक ग
गिट हब है रिपोजिटरी है वे बैक
यूआरएल गिट हब यह देखिए टॉम
दिस वन और सिंपली मैं क्या करूंगा इसको
यूज कर सकता हूं यहां से इसको हमें क्या
करना है गिट क्लोन करना है हमें कॉपी किया
और सिंपली मैं अभी क्या करता हूं सीडी बैक
करता हूं वन स्टेप क्लियर नाउ उसके बाद हम
क्या करेंगे गिट क्लोन
चलो डन
एलएस उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे नेक्स्ट हम
बात करें इसको वेबक ल्स
की डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट हुई होगी यह रहा
सीडी वे बैक यूरल हिट एंटर एल एस इसके बाद
हमारे पास क्या य पर एक स्क्रिप्ट है तो
तो मेन डॉट गो उसके बाद आपको क्या करना
[संगीत]
है गेट क्लोन किया उसके बाद में
डायरेक्टली यूज करना चाहिए था मुझे क्लियर
बैक सीडी
बैक वे बक य डायरेक्टरी बट व्ट इ द इशू
विद ट ओके मुझे एक बार चेक करने
दीजिए कैट
ओके इसको मैं कॉपी करता हूं अभी के
लिए मे बी व्ट इ द इशू विद माय मशीन
म भी बोल नहीं रहा
वेट मुझे भी गो लैंग्वेज इसके लिए क्या
होना गो तो होती है सिस्टम में मे भी आईम
गेटिंग समथिंग मैं इसको चेक करता हूं
कुछ ओके वे बैक
देन मुझे गो लैंग्वेज को इंस्टॉल करना
होगा किसके अंदर अपने
पेज नोट फाउंड आ रहा है यार ब्रो कोही तो
इशू है
वेट वेट वेट
तो गाइ ये काम करते हैं आज का टाइम हो गया
वैसे वन एंड हाफ आवर्स हो गया है तो एक
काम करते हैं हम यहां से स्टार्ट करते हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में मे
बी हां मे बी प्रॉब्लम इज दैट कि मेरी
मशीन का इशू आ रहा है तो हम एक काम करते
हैं कि ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे तो
वे बैक यूरल से हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास के अंदर कुछ इश्यूज है जो
मैं सॉल्व कर लूंगा मशीन चेंज कर
लेंगे ओके तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग से पहले जो हमारा अभी
कुछ टूल्स बच गए हैं जैसे वे बैक यूआरएल
है इसमें जो मैं आपको करवाने वाला था वह
चीजें आपकी बच गई है तो हम नेक्स्ट क्लास
में कंटिन्यू करते हैं इससे ओके तो कोई
किसी को कोई इशू तो नहीं है तो सभी ने
किया हो आई थिंक क्लास के अंदर किसी को
बोर नहीं लगा होगा और शायद नई चीजें आपको
सीखने को मिली
होंगी क्योंकि कुछ टूल्स ऐसे होंगे जो
पहली बार कुछ लोग देख रहे होंगे कुछ टूल्स
है कि किसी को पता होगा तो यूज करना छोड़
दिया होगा तो तो वे बैक यूरल से हम क्या
करेंगे ऑटोमेशन प्रोसेस से फिर से करेंगे
ओके स्टार्ट अपना कंटिन्यू काम करेंगे
ओके चलो तो एक काम करते हैं आज का सेशन
यही पर एंड करते हैं और हम मिलेंगे
नेक्स्ट क्लास में जल्दी मिलेंगे क्योंकि
अभी पहला आपका पैसिव रिकॉन कंप्लीट करवाना
हो उसके बाद हम
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में हम एंटर
करेंगे तो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है क्योंकि
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग से आपकी जर्नी जो
स्टार्ट होगी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग जर्नी आपकी
स्टार्ट होगी तो आपको चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं उसके लिए तो कुछ टूल्स बच जाएंगे उस
पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग है वो कंप्लीट
करेंगे देन एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हम
नेक्स्ट कर तो मे भी एक वन मोर सेशन
जिसमें हमें इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
रिगार्डिंग टू पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन पढ़ना
होगा उसके बाद सेकंड सेशन जो स्टार्ट होगा
उसके बाद वो एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग से
करना होगा तो तब तक के लिए
बाय बाय गुड नाइट हां वन मोर थिंग अगर
किसी को कोई भी डाउट्स है तो
प्लीज सेशन एंड होने के बाद जो वीडियोज
अपलोड होती है पे वहां पर कमेंट सेक्शन
में आप पूछ सकते हैं मुझसे मैं आपके डाउट
वहां पर नोट डाउन करता हूं और जो डाउट
डिस्कस करने के सेम टाइम रिप्लाई करता हूं
अदर वाइज मैं क्या करता हूं उन डाउट्स को
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम डिस्कस
करेंगे चलो बाय बाय गुड नाइट टेक केयर अब
हम मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट सेशन में